six years ago this week tim tebow the
football player and his Super Bowl ad
caused a really big stir initially the
idea was this is an anti-abortion ad Tim
Tebow known to be religious a Christian
devout Christian etc and it started so
much controversy and we'll talk about
some of the controversy but first if you
don't remember the ad or if you never
saw it let's play that and then discuss
I call in my miracle baby he almost
didn't make it into this world I can
remember so many times when I almost
lost him it was so hard well he's all
grown up now and I still worry about his
self you know with all our families been
through have to be tough Timmy we're
trying to tell our story here you still
worry about me Mom oh yeah tough as I am
okay so was it an anti-abortion ad they
it is Focus on the Family which is an
anti-abortion group it says celebrate
life which is certainly a reference to
not having abortion but then that's
where the controversy exploded because
there's not that much really said in the
ad it's more just the focus on the
family the branding celebrate life
Gloria Allred the attorney said she
thought whatever Tim Tebow's mom meant
by you almost didn't make it into this
world that it was made up anyway or that
it certainly had no reference to
abortion this entire thing blew blew up
and what I came away thinking after this
is I don't really care about Tim Tebow
that was the big takeaway I had I don't
think you cared about him before exactly
I think it's just it's just an
advertisement for the group a
religiously tinged advertisement for the
group I Tim Tebow was on the Patriots
for a little while and this was very
scary to me yeah but he didn't last long
no he didn't have athletes become more
or less political would you say since
this incident I mean we saw Steve Nash
for example who is Canadian born but a
American basketball player make a number
of political comments about who he
supports a very progressive guy we have
seen you know Charles Barkley for
example become political sort of known
as a Republican for a long time but then
more recently making a pro democratic
Pro progressive statements we've seen it
football broadcaster al michaels make
that comment when John Kerry was running
of course that was after this incident
when they were broadcasting a Patriots
game saying the referees flip-flopped on
the call and were certainly in the right
state for that right we've seen the
sports world sort of have elements of
politics and sports themselves can be
very political but do you think that
athletes themselves are becoming more
openly political or less i I really
don't know I guess over the course of
probably over the course of the past 10
years I would say more or at least when
they are it's getting more attention but
with with social media and the way that
has evolved yeah I think it makes things
much easier for them to get their
message out there do you like it when
athletes talk about their political
views or are you one of the types of
people that says I don't care nor do I
want to know I only care about what
they're doing on the field no if if it's
an athlete well I guess it depends on if
it's an athlete that I admire or or like
exactly and so yeah I would I would like
to hear sure I would like to hear what
Tom Brady thinks about politics yeah
maybe I wouldn't but this is where I get
it you know the problem is I like
hearing about athletes politics and if
it's athletes that I like
I obviously love it if I find out that
they're progressive but if an athlete I
like is a right-wing nut it really does
impact my the future of my understanding
and interpretation of that person is
irrevocably inextricably tinged by my
knowledge about their right-wing
politics that is the reality and you
know there are a lot of right-wing
athletes out there you know Curt
Schilling the Red Sox former pitcher
great pitcher ever since I found out
that he was a total right winger I just
don't really like Curt Schilling anymore
quite frankly I couldn't care about him
being in the Hall of Fame or not and
blah blah blah it just it really turns
me off when they're right wing nuts but
then I thought hey it turns me off when
anybody's a right wing nut it doesn't
matter if it's an athlete mm-hmm so like
that question we answered can you
separate yeah you know can you separate
what do you call it the question we're
gonna talk about later today
yeah can you separate an artist from
there
from their art can you separate an
athlete from their political beliefs I I
guess I can but I'm always gonna think
about Tom Brady with that Donald Trump
hat in his locker
absolutely no doubt about that Warby
Parker is offering a free five day home
Tryon to give you the opportunity to
check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed dot-com
slash TDP s I don't really like going
into glasses stores and trying on
glasses while the salesperson sort of
hovers over me and I like more than 30
seconds to actually figure out whether I
like the glasses so with the Warby
Parker home Tryon I was able to pick
five pairs that I liked put them on in
the comfort of my own home pick the one
I like the most and then Warby Parker
put my prescription lenses in there for
me a lot of people don't know that the
eyeglass industry is controlled by just
a few big corporations that keep prices
very high like $300 for prescription
glasses hi which is just insane Warby
Parker glasses start at $95 that's what
mine cost and for every pair of glasses
sold Warby Parker distributes a pair of
glasses to someone in need you can try
five pairs and see what you like check
out the at home trial and support our
show by going to Warby Parker comm slash
TDP s it costs nothing